[Aplausos]
el proyecto se llama planea tu familia
y
[Música]
y la idea se originó hace más o menos
nueve meses
prácticamente como un embrión
y hoy nace este bebé
los padres y madres
de este bebé son de finagro sí
lucia molinari
fernando al niño y un servidor
delphi luz y fer
son expertos en comunicación
y son los responsables de mucho de lo
que voy a mostrar aquí
y además son activistas en diversidad
yo soy médico
trabajo en medicina de la reproducción
hace más de 40 años
y durante esos 40 años he sido testigo
histórico
no solo de cómo ha cambiado
tecnológicamente
el poder ayudar a gente a tener bebés
pero también he sido testigo histórico
de cómo ha ido cambiando el aspecto de
diversidad
dentro del tema de la fertilidad
planeta tu familia es un sitio
que es abierto y es interactivo para
ayudar a todas las personas que tengan
interés en informarse cómo desarrollar
una familia
tenemos una visión de un mundo inclusivo
que todas las familias puedan
desarrollarse en un marco de acceso
democratizado a la información igualdad
de oportunidades y sin ningún tipo de
discriminación
la misión es posible de informar y
explicarle
a todo tipo de
pareja o persona
cómo poder lograr el objetivo
de tener una familia
hoy vamos a hablar de tres temas
y espero poder ajustar me a los 18
minutos que me han dado
vamos a hablar de familia vamos a hablar
de diversidad
y de fertilidad
y luego finalmente explicar cómo
realmente
trabaja la plataforma que hemos
desarrollado
cuando empezamos tratando de buscar y
ponerle un nombre a este bebé
y llegamos a coincidir en que planea tu
familia sería interesante
tuvimos que definir que era familia
porque a través de la historia el
concepto de familia ha ido cambiando
muchísimo como ustedes bien lo saben
y nos pusimos a leer de todo desde los
trabajos originales de marx engels hasta
autores contemporáneos que no decían que
era una familia
y la verdad que pocas definiciones de
todas las que leíamos
nos convencían mucho esta es una
definición de familia de la organización
mundial de la salud
que dice que es un conjunto de personas
bajo el mismo techo con roles fijos esto
es muy importante con vínculos cosas
niños o no con un modo de existencia
económica y social comunes con
sentimientos afectivos que los reúnen
después de leer muchísimas definiciones
llegamos a la conclusión de que
queríamos crear nuestra propia
definición
y esta es la definición de familia de
planea tu familia
es una composición social con
integrantes de iguales o diferentes
sexos o sea ya lo estamos especificando
de igual esos diferentes orígenes
territoriales o religiosos de un mismo
origen biológico no unidos formal o
informalmente con una convivencia fin
social económica y afectiva lo que
realmente lo reúne
he sido como le dije antes testigo
histórico de cómo a través de todos los
últimos 40 años
la aplicación de técnicas de fertilidad
ha ido cambiando y no solamente aplicado
a la típica pareja tradicional binaria
heterosexual
pero vemos parejas homosexuales
femeninas homosexuales masculinas
mujeres solas solteras hombres solos y
últimamente
transexuales masculinos y transexuales
femeninos
todo ese popurrí de universidades de
núcleos familiares esta caricatura
lizado en esta diapositiva
qué
esta diapositiva que no hace falta
leerla en detalle solamente quiere
indicar
la falta de aprobación mundial
homogénea que existe para aceptar todo
este tipo de diversas núcleos familiares
hay países donde si se aceptan
matrimonios de parejas del mismo sexo
otros donde se protege la discriminación
contra el colectivo lgtb y muy pocos
países sólo 5 constituciones en el mundo
que protegen a las minorías sexuales
lo que sí sabemos y esto está
ampliamente documentado
que la pareja o la persona que no
corresponde a la tradicional binario
heterosexual
tienen hijos ya
de vidas previas o tienen intención de
tener hijos o sea más de la mitad de
todas estas personas o parejas quieren
tener una familia propia
en este caso
de estas dos mujeres que esos pacientes
y querían saber qué tiene que hacer una
persona en la situación de ellas de una
pareja homosexual femenina para poder
llevar a cabo su sueño de tener una
familia
nos dicen esto teníamos la certeza de
que queríamos agrandar la familia pero
no sabíamos por dónde empezar nos llevó
muchísimo tiempo entender cuáles eran
nuestras opciones tanto desde una
perspectiva legal como médica
nos emocionamos al saber que otras
familias pueden acortar esos plazos con
esta plataforma de planear tu familia de
forma clara y sencilla
y ayudará a traer más amor al mundo
el tercer tema que íbamos a hablar
dijimos al inicio fue fertilidad
todos los que estamos aquí todos
fuimos originados
por una célula igual que ésta
una célula que tiene dos pronúcleos uno
femenino y uno masculino
y en base a eso creamos el concepto
inicial de planea tu familia
se necesitan para procrear tres
componentes
un óvulo
un espermatozoide
yo no otro
hasta ahora
en el año 2019 hace falta esto
quizás en un futuro cambio
cuando diseñamos esto nos encantó tanto
este corazón que lo convertimos en el
logo de nuestra plataforma
en los últimos 40 años también fuimos
testigos del crecimiento y desarrollo
tecnológico en el área de fertilidad
y estas técnicas que están descritas
sacan inseminación intrauterina
fertilización in vitro inyección
intracitoplasmática de espermatozoides y
transferencias man arias son quizás las
más comunes de todas las que se usan
algo que es importante que ustedes sepan
[Música]
que hasta el año pasado 2018 ya habían
nacido en el mundo
más de 8 millones de bebés por estas
técnicas de reproducción asistida
quizás lo va a sorprender todavía más a
ustedes cuando yo les diga que en eeuu
uno de cada 60 bebés que nace
es por un tratamiento de reproducción
asistida
y en países como dinamarca israel japón
uno cada 25 que nace estos reproducción
asistida y esto va todavía aumentando y
aumentando
es por eso que es muy obvio que en una
audiencia como la de hoy con toda la
gente que hay
hay varias siguientes aquí que fueron
concebidas de esta manera
este es un típico ejemplo de una de esas
técnicas que es inyectar en un óvulo por
medio de una microaguja un
espermatozoide para producir esa célula
con dos pronúcleos que vimos al inicio
hace aproximadamente 30 años
yo presente en una sociedad de
fertilidad en eeuu
un concepto
que se llamó las 25 maneras de conseguir
y estas 25 maneras de concebir era un
algoritmo creado por las distintas
posibles combinaciones de óvulos
espermatozoides y úteros de quien sea y
como esas combinaciones pueden ser y la
posibilidad son 25
30 años atrás me trataron de psicópata
prácticamente
pero
pero duro esto
ahora le voy a aplicar como se aplica en
la plataforma que tenemos
la plataforma de planea tu familia es
una plataforma interactiva donde la
persona o pareja entran
a la plataforma
y se me hacen una serie de preguntas y
esas preguntas llevan a una serie de
filtros y los filtros llevan a
respuestas
en este caso por ejemplo le preguntan la
identidad de género en este ejemplo
mujer
su identidad de sexo biológico mujer
también
y si quiere formar una familia con una
pareja o sin pareja en este caso
selecciona con pareja
sexo biológico de tu pareja mujer
también entonces en este caso
arriba de todo identidad de género mujer
sexo biológico mujer con pareja sexo
biológico de la pareja mujer
a la derecha oa la izquierda perdón se
le pregunta si es con óvulo propio por
la edad de la mujer o por si tiene
ovarios o no los tiene y si es con útero
propio o no
de acuerdo a esto
la plataforma era el resultado exacto de
cuáles son los pasos que tienen que
seguir en este caso sería obviamente si
son dos mujeres donación de semen
y luego podría ser o inseminación
intrauterina o fertilización in vitro
con transferencia embrionario
este es otro ejemplo una identidad de
que nueva mujer sexo biológico mujer con
pareja sexo biológico mujer pero que
quieren o necesitan utilizar un útero
lleno un útero
subrogado entonces en este caso por ser
dos mujeres necesitan donación de semen
fertilización in vitro e icsi
transferencia en bernard ya gestación
sustituta
para cada caso posible
existe una solución existe una oferta
médica
en cada uno de estos componentes del
menú existe un contenido en la
plataforma que explica exactamente cómo
lo tienen que hacer
lo que originariamente fue algo tan
bonito
qué era lo que habíamos considerado para
una pareja binaria tradicional
heterosexual hoy en día este corazón se
convierte en múltiples corazones con
muchas otras posibilidades de cómo
conseguir y ayudar a familias
diversas a poder tener sus bebés
sus ángulos
es una psicóloga de cambridge
en la directora del centro de estudios
familiares ha dedicado toda su vida
a evaluar
él parenting y el desarrollo infantil
[Música]
en núcleos familiares diversos
homosexualismo femenino masculino
mujeres solas hombres solos todo lo que
estuvimos hablando en esta charla
susan golón box tiene una ventaja que
sus estudios son longitudinales y
continúan a los niños hasta los 21 años
de edad que tienen datos irrefutables
susana acaba de sacar un libro que
además familias modernas
y ella dice que la estructura familiar
es mucho menos importante para el
bienestar de los niños que la calidad de
las relaciones familiares y a veces
cuanto más inusual parezca la estructura
familiar en realidad mejores son las
relaciones porque estos son padres que
realmente quieren tener hijos y eso es
lo más importante
para finalizar solamente una cita de
el escritor del principito que dijo que
no tenemos que olvidarnos nunca que cada
uno de nosotros puede ser la ocasión de
un hombre diverso muchas gracias
[Aplausos]